another con not taking place this summer
is star wars celebration was supposed to
take place in august and we were looking
forward to learning everything we could
about the mandalorian
season two but throughout quarantine i
have been talking to the cast and
creators and i've got
plenty of tea to share with you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
just looking ahead to season two a
little bit because coven19 has just like
halted everything
have you guys been impacted on the
season two front for
for mandalorian at all well i won't talk
too much about it but i i will say that
you know we are working away and we are
we're pretty fortunate we're in a really
good position to do the work we're doing
um so john and i are just all in on it
at this point
uh i i won't talk too much about the tv
show i always like to
have john with me when we talk about
that stuff you know because we're such a
team on that
and uh you know i i really have enjoyed
working with him and it's been a really
fun collaboration you know
uh neither of us really could have
guessed that the reaction that the show
got
i am no jedi
yeah the fans have been pushing for a
sugar channel for a minute now
oh yes which would be so campaign i know
like someone said the art and then i
reposted it and then star wars started
following me and then everybody started
thinking it was a whole thing and it's
just literally
been this internet situation so internet
if it happens
it's because of you and now here we are
well then we have nothing confirmed
right now so and when that happens i'll
be very excited
but literal fan cast that would be
that would be the day i'd i'd be able to
look up the exact moment the exact tweet
and the exact
christening of this entire you know
dream experience
if it were to be confirmed but wait
got my legs crossed got my eyes crossed
got my fingers crossed
i'm gonna cross my like tattoo finger
here
[Music]
have you heard the rumor that boba fett
might be in the new season therefore
having survived the sarlacc pit no
i thought it was i thought he was
decades into being digested
at this point it takes place i guess
after returning to the jedi and before
the sequel so yeah you know like i say
there's so
many ways they can go but those two uh
john favreau and dave filoni they're
both
just the right person in the right job
because they know
they know it better than i do but people
are looking in the background being like
is that boba fett or what's going on
interesting
interesting yeah interesting you think
there's a possibility he survived the
sarlacc interesting interesting
interesting i mean there's always
possibilities i don't like to limit our
storytelling in any way and
you know who knows i've been surprised
it would be really hypocritical for the
guy that helped bring darth maul back to
life after he got cut in half for me to
say that
somebody can't survive a sarlacc pit but
i don't know you know i mean
anything's possible in star wars and i
always think when fans love something
that's what really fuels the possibility
and the believability so
who knows
i have to know your reaction when you
found out you were going to be wielding
the dark saber and what it looks like on
set because it was one of the most
badass shots i've ever seen
i have to say it's um such an honor you
know very few have wielded that saber
it just was really wonderful to be in
the organic
version of this story
john favreau asked me to do it i was
head over heels he mentioned that he had
written it for me
i went and started to look at old mops
what's a moth
you know i went back and looked at peter
cushing was a moth you know what do they
do
who are they uh and then was really
present in conversations with john about
his imperial status his carryover from
the empire
um how moss operated why
possibly leaving room it's always
possibly
why he might be um the moth to take
everything over
how does he know everything there were a
bunch of questions and so
which some of them got answered and many
of them not because he's still trying to
find that out
so to be in the position of having that
kind of regal
graceful power but have this saver which
delineates a different part of me
than any other character um
to have this saber means i'm i'm i can
use it
and i can do my own dirty work that i'm
a fighter that i'm a warrior that's part
of me
also creates the possibility of
that he um is
uh you know one of the ones
you know like he possibly has that
and that to me
is interesting because is he really that
fallen hero
is he you know uh is he
a descendant of darth vader who is he
what does he want
he knows all about everything and you'll
have to wait to find out
yeah he's actually pretty good with that
dark saver too okay
and you found out that like his whole
drive in the first season was just to go
after this
adorable little baby yoda like what did
you think
so to be tied to this baby is great just
don't let me catch you in season two
i know you better not you better not
hurt him
but but you never know i just want to
spend all my time with him so as close
as i can
get i will get and believe me i'm good
at getting close